>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGHAM
AND IS IS "THE INAHAMNGLE"
ON A VERY BY FDAY NIGHT.
SWIMMING TXTINION.
THAT IS THE FUS OONIG'S
"ANGL
I THINK THE GDELINES THEY
SET FORWARARE VER GOOD A DO
A VE GOOD B OF PROTING
INCLIVITY WHI KEEPINGCOMPOSITNAN
LL INTEGRITYEAH THOMAS
BELIEVES THE WHY SHATTEDAST
NIT AT THE IVY LGUE
AMPIONSHIP.
>>HOMAS HEADS I FORHE FINAL
RN.
IT'S GOING TOE AACE FOR
SECO PLA AND GOING 1,
MAKING THE TN CUENTLY IN
SECOND PLACE.
OVER THEAST HF, NOBODY WILL
FINISHING ED:37.32.
AH THOMAS, IVY LEAGUE CHAM
CHPION.
>>aura: THOMAS NOT OY WON
THE00-YARD FRETYLEACE.
RECORD FOR HARRD UVERSITY'SPOOL.
EV THE ANNOUNCER KINOF
TATLY ADMITTE THA IT WAS IN
THE TRAING, TEDICATION TO
THE CRAFT THAT WAESPONSIBLEFOR G
ELSE.
>> Y CANEE T STROKE,HE
PORFUL STROKE OF LEAH THOMAS
WHERTHERISN'T A WHOLE L OF
MOVENT IER LEG
SHE'S ING LOT OF UER BODY
REACH AND PUL ANDT'S A
MU QUIER SOKE EVEN IF IS
MO POWERFUL THAN LOTF THE
>> Laura: I MN, YOU CAN'T
SAY UT ANYBO WHO KWS THE
BACS OF COMTITI SWIMMG
ALIZ THAT DERIVIN POW
FR ONLY T ARMS ISN'T N
NATURATHIS IS022,F COURSE TMAS
WAS N THE ONLY FST AITTED
TO THE TOP OTHE PODIU
ISAAC D TAN A TRANSGENDE
MAWHOS NOT EVEN YE BUN
HORME THERAPY AND SLL
MAINELIGIBLE TO SW ON T
MAN'S TM SET A N POO RECORD
IN THE 50-RD FRETYLE.
WHAT IS WNG HE?
E W A CILIZION OF
AMERICS RELY OKAY WITH WHAT
ARE WITSSING?
ISVERYONE AFRAIDO SPEAKUT?
IT'S HEARTBREAK ITHE WOR
OFHOMAHISEAMMATES.ONE ANONYMOUSN
DECEMBER DESIBED HER TEAMMATTO G
FEELING "SOISCOAGED BECAUSE
NO MATTER HOW MUCH WK THEY PUT
IN THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE.
"A MONTH LATER, ANOTHER TOLD
FOX WS TT THE NCAAOESN
ACTUALLY CE ABOUT WOMAN ANDALL.
WELLI HE TO SAY TS BU
SHS RIGHT
LAST MONTH T NCA TOOK THECOWARDE
WOULD DEF TOHE RULES OF EACH
SPOR AND THEIROVERNING BOD
TO DETERMI THE ELIGIBILI OF
TRANTHLETES.
WHENSA SWIMMINGELEAD AN
UPDATE TOWDS I POLICY A
UPLE WEEKS BACREQUING THE
ANSGENDER WOMEN TOAVE HALF
THPREVIOUS LEVELF
TEOSTERONE,HEY WERE
IGINALLY ALLOWOOMPETE
THNCAA STEPPED IN TO CE THE
TRIMTAL IMPACT T SCHOOLS
AND ATHLET.
ST WK THE NCAA SAID IT WOUNOT AY
APPROVED HIGHER TESTOSTERE
CLEARING THE W FORHOMAS TOBE IND
XTONTH.
ESE FELLOW SWIMMERS KW TH
ENRE EXERCISE IS CHARADE.
SO WHY WON'T THE STA UP AND
FUSE TOARTIPATE?
I WL TL YOU WHY THEARE
INTIMIDATE BECSEHE ENTIRY
OF SOCTY WGHING AGAINST
EM.
THE ACHEARE COWAR, ONE
SWIMMER FROM PENN SD PRETTY
MUCH EVERYDY INDIVIDUALL HSPOKET
LIKI THI
OU COA JUST REALLY KES
WINNG THOUGH.
THE MED THEN OF CRSECHEERLEADS X
ROLES,N AUAL REPORTER FOR "THE '
"LEA THOMASS JUST THEATEST
CENTURY WHO'S BN SUECT TO
ORMONONOKE SCRUTINY
".
ONE ING EY HAVE IN COMMON,
THEY WE WINNING.
COUE, THEY PUSH T
PROPANDA.
STATE OFFICIALTO T PARENTS
WHO ARE CONCERN TT CISGENDER
TRANSGENDER ATETESP BY
>> ISO REASONO BELIEVEHAT.
THERE'S BEEN N POF
ANSGENDEREOPLE EVERDOMINATE INP.
ARE PARTICIPANG WH OURPEERS.
Laura: I LOVTHIS
I LL TEL THA TO THE GIR I
E POLL LAST NHT.
THE MOST POWERFUL LIBALS IN
AMICA ENCOURAGE IT.
>>HE GDANCE FOR SCHOOLSTRANS GIT
AND WITH SIRLS
BELIEF IS THA TRANS RIGS A
HUN RITS AND THAT'SHY HE
SIGN EXETIVE ORDER.
>> IELIEVE THEY SHLD OER
E OPPORTUNITY TONGAG IN
EXTRACURRICULA ACTITIESVEN
IF THEY ARE TNSGEER IT THEIR
GHT.
>> Lra: WT AUT THE
RIGH OF THE GIRLSN THE YNG
DECADES.TRA FOR YEARSND
IN PURSUITF TIR
EATNESS AND PU RECORDS.
IT IS TOO BAD AORDING TO THE
OF T CULRE.ND PRETTYUCH ALL
LIKEVERYTHING ELSE I THE PAS
O YRS, IT I LEFT TO G.O.P.GOVERR
PRCIPLE.
SEVEL STATES HAVEASSED LAWS
OTECTING GROSSORTSY
EPINGRANSNDER GIRLS,
COLLEGE AG WEN FRO PLAYING
IN SCHOOL SRTSEAGUES
MATCNG THEIR GENDER IDENTITY.
THEY INCLUDE FLORIDA, TEXAS,
SSISPPI, SOUTH DAKA, ANG
HERS.
TH'S INTERESTING WRE HAV
WE SEEN THE STATESEADI THEWAY B?
COVID.IT TAKESOREHAN STATECTIONT
AN YOU C FIN A JUDGE TO
OVERRN PRETTY MUC ATHIN
THESE DAYS.
WE HAVE SEEN F VGINI AND
CALIRNIA, EVEWHER IN
TWEE WHEN CONCERNECITIZENS
T TOTHER ON AFRAID ANDPUSHED BKD
COON SEN, BASIC BIOLO,
RENTAND NEIBORSAY THIS
JUST N WHAT WE WANT F OUR
FUTUREND KS FUTES.
YOU CAN ALL ME A DIFFEREE.
THE ISSUEF WHAT'S GOINGN IN
THE PLS, TRACK A FIELD, GL
ORTS, WOMEN SRT